tenemos una transformación que va de r2
en r2 y de hecho déjenme dibujar
nuestras ya clásicas burbujas tenemos
aquí una transformación que toma
elementos en r2 y al aplicarles la
transformación me arroja otros elementos
de r2 y de hecho esta transformación por
ser lineal que vamos a decir que es
lineal digamos que está dada por esta
multiplicación de esta matriz de esta
matriz x por cualquier vector ok la
matriz 1 - 3 - 13 entonces para tratar
de entender mejor este lo que lo que
está haciendo esta transformación
pensemos en los valores que puede tomar
en el condominio es decir estaremos
pensando si todo r2 puede cubrirse por
por la imagen de puntos de r2 o si sólo
alguna parte de r2 o qué sé yo entonces
pensemos que por ejemplo ese si esta es
la matriz
un poco más grande eso esta es nuestra
matriz
entonces si nos tomamos un x particular
y lo multiplicamos tenemos uno menos
tres menos 13 y digamos que si x pues es
el vector que tiene como coordenadas x1
y x2 queremos ver si nos tomamos
inicialmente un punto en r2 cuando
existe otro vector x tal que al
multiplicarlo por la matriz nos da b1 b2
donde por supuesto estamos pensando que
este vector d es el que tiene
coordenadas b1 b2 ok entonces en otras
palabras estamos haciendo esta
multiplicación de a equis y estamos
viendo para cuales ve esta
multiplicación es posible es decir
cuáles son las veces posibles para las
cuales lo podemos expresar expresar como
la matriz a por un vector x en r2 y para
hacer eso pues recordarás que
necesitamos regresar a nuestra técnica
de reducir la matriz aumentada
a su forma reducida y escalonada por
renglones verdad entonces lo que tenemos
que hacer inicialmente es tomarnos la
matriz ésta
aquí es uno menos tres menos 13 y además
la tenemos que aumentar con el vector b1
b2 si nosotros reducimos a su forma
reducida y escalonada por renglones
entonces podremos ver para cuales b1 y
b2
nosotros tenemos una solución de esto y
de hecho trabajamos un poco de eso en él
en el vídeo anterior entonces si
nosotros empezamos a trabajar sobre de
esta matriz sobre esta matriz lo que
vamos a tener es por ejemplo podemos
dejar fijo el primer renglón 1 menos 3 y
luego b 1 lo dejamos esto fijo y ahora
al primer renglón se lo sumamos al
segundo ok entonces tenemos 1 + menos 1
nos da 0 menos 33 es cero y b1 b2 pues
me queda b1 b2 aquí es donde justo de
este lado derecho nos queda en términos
de
son expresiones en términos de b1 y b2
verdad que era justo lo que discutíamos
en el vídeo anterior
entonces si nos damos cuenta que hay
algo muy pero muy muy interesante porque
justamente tenemos un renglón completito
en donde hay puros ceros y para que esto
sea cierto lo que debe pasar es que esto
de acá a la derecha tiene que ser
necesariamente cero aunque entonces si
inicialmente nos tomamos ve digamos un
vector que tiene coordenadas b1 y b2 si
inicialmente empezamos así entonces solo
elementos sólo elementos
digamos este les llamamos ve que se
encuentran en nuestro r2 como co dominio
que tienen solución
estamos buscando las veces que tienen
solución
sólo aquellos son aquellos son aquellos
aquellos ves por supuesto que satisfacen
esta relación que b1 b2 debe ser
exactamente cero entonces tal que b1 b2
es igual a cero o bien esto es
equivalente si pasamos el b1 del otro
lado a quevedos es menos de uno verdad
entonces vamos a dibujar esto vamos a
dibujar esto en el plano digamos
bajamos primero unos ejes y se me queda
un poco chueco
ya está me pase esto es b1 ok entonces
dibujamos unos ejes que me queden más o
menos derechitos
ahí está nuestro primer eje ok y
dibujemos otro eje el otro eje de r2
fue mucho más sencillo ok entonces aquí
tenemos nuestros ejes
y lo que vamos a hacer es tratar de
dibujar qué puntos en r2 satisfacen que
son solución de esta ecuación y veremos
que no es todo r 2 verdad porque si
tenemos una restricción sobre nuestros
vectores entonces esencialmente si aquí
tenemos b 1 y acabe 2 me está diciendo
que b 2 es menos b 1 que eso se ve como
esta función identidad pero al revés
verdad menos la función identidad más
este esta línea amarilla es justo
nuestro conjunto solución de esta
ecuación de aquí entonces esto de aquí
lo que estamos diciendo es que son todas
las b todos los vectores b
digamos ajá que tienen solución que
tienen solución
tiene quien no tienes no que tienen
solución ok y por supuesto estamos
pensando que nuestro dominio aquí es r 2
muy bien entonces esto esta línea
también la podemos pensar que son justo
todos los vectores que pueden expresarse
como a por equis pero esto es la
transformación aplicado a x entonces
toda esta línea no es otra cosa más que
la imagen la imagen de nuestra
transformación y aquí por supuesto
estamos viviendo en el co dominio verdad
estamos considerando todas las veces
para las cuales esto es cierto entonces
qué es lo que estamos diciendo también
no es cierto que todo r2 lo podemos
expresar como a por equis verdad no es
cierto que todas las veces son solución
a esta ecuación quiere decir que si por
ejemplo aquí tenemos r 2 ok
aquí tenemos r 2
quiere decir que debe haber varios
vectores varios vectores que al
aplicarle la transformación pues van a
dar al mismo punto y eso es porque como
vimos en el vídeo anterior pues no va a
ser
perdón su proyectiva o sobre la tras la
transformación y por lo tanto no va a
ser invertible verdad entonces
recordemos que para que una
transformación sea su proyectiva lo que
necesitamos es que a la hora de hacer
esta forma reducida necesitamos m
entradas pivotes en este caso m tendría
que ser 2 y no lo tenemos justamente
verdad entonces si recordamos
básicamente lo que queremos es ver quién
es la imagen de nuestra transformación
al ver quiénes son todos los ves
posibles que satisfacen esta ecuación a
x igual a b y al reducir la matriz
aumentada llegamos a que tiene que ser
este conjunto esta línea de puntos
entonces vamos a ir ahora al revés qué
pasaría si nosotros nos tomamos
punto en esta línea entonces
supongamos supongamos ahora que tenemos
un punto que satisface que b1 b2 es
igual a cero ok entonces la pregunta es
que conjuntos es decir nos estamos
considerando un punto particular aquí
nos tomamos uno particular el que más te
guste y una vez que nos tomamos eso nos
preguntamos ahora cuáles son todos los
puntos en r2 que van a dar a este punto
rosa en particular y si tomamos nuestra
amat esta multiplicación vamos a notar
que como veo no es menos de 2 entonces
sólo tenemos una restricción verdad esto
es multiplicamos esta matriz y vemos que
tenemos x 1 menos 3 x 2 es igual a b 1 y
de hecho bueno voy a hacer la segunda
multiplicación tenemos menos x 1 más 3 x
2 es igual a b 2 que es menos
1 entonces si nos damos cuenta son las
mismas ecuaciones solo que la segunda es
la primera multiplicada por un menos uno
así que voy a quitar la realmente solo
tenemos esta esta restricción y si
despejamos x1 obtenemos b 1
b 1 + 3 veces x 2 ok entonces si tomamos
un punto que está en la imagen de la
transformación
ahora quiero preguntarme qué vectores
van a dar bajo la transformación a este
punto y sabemos que deben ser varios
porque la transformación es es sobre es
su proyectiva verdad que entonces no es
invertible en fin muy bien entonces
vamos a ver si yo expreso entonces un
vector x 1 x 2
tenemos un vector x 1 x 2 y este vector
va a dar al al punto al vector b este
vector de entonces x 1 me dice que lo
podemos expresar como b 1 + 3 x 2 ok
entonces digamos b 1 es aquí está b 1
más
x 2 x 3 verdad por 3 y como expresamos a
x2 pues 0 + una vez x2 muy bien entonces
todos los vectores que van a dar a este
particular a este a este particular son
de esta forma son de esta forma entonces
vamos a ir escribiendo este resultado
para un para un elemento de vector b
particular y que debe cumplir este
particular pues que tiene solución
verdad que tiene solución
de esta ecuación de la ecuación a x
igual a b si nos tomamos 1 que tiene
solución entonces de hecho el conjunto
solución
el conjunto solución de esa ecuación
para el b particular es de la siguiente
forma desde la forma son todos los
vectores x 1 x 2 de la forma del
igual de la forma b 10 + un escalar aquí
lo voy a denotar como x 2 pero puede ser
cualquier escalar 3 1 ok entonces mi
conjunto solución es justamente todos
aquellos b 10 que le sumamos un múltiplo
de 3 1 cómo se vería esto vamos a ver
cómo se vería esto
digamos que de este lado tengo la imagen
ya no voy a hacer las burbujas ya voy a
ser realmente a r2
este eje
mucho cuidado para no irnos tan chicos
muy bien entonces ahí está mi eje acá
tenemos
el otro de los ejes otra vez me fui
chueco
y es más o menos el otro eje y
justamente la imagen dijimos que era
esta línea que es menos la identidad
verdad esta línea es la imagen de la
transformación entonces qué pasa si por
ejemplo yo me tomo un punto particular
digamos me tomo este punto de aquí que
fuera del vector b digamos el 5 menos 5
verdad este cumple que es parte de de la
de la imagen verdad porque la suma de
sus coordenadas debe dar pero entonces
nos tomamos este particular de aquí y
vamos a ver cuáles son todos los
vectores que se encuentran en
nr 2 que al aplicarles la transformación
van al 5 menos 5
entonces volvemos a pintar los ejes
dar los ejes
cuidado para no irnos chuecos que ahí
está uno más o menos
tenemos ahí el otro muy bien entonces me
dice que mi conjunto solución es el
conjunto x1 es decir si x es igual más
bien si x es igual a 5 menos 5 quiere
decir entonces que el conjunto de
soluciones de la forma x 1 x 2 son según
esta fórmula que tenemos aquí b 1 que en
este caso es 50 más x 2 o cualquier
escalar por el 3 1
entonces si pintamos esto aquí digamos
aquí tenemos el 50
yéndome mucho últimamente entonces si
tenemos este vector 50 y ahora nos
fijamos en el 31
y vamos a hacerlo con otro verde
si ahora nos fijamos en el 31 digamos 1
2 3 y 1 entonces este vector al irle
sumando lo que lo que tenemos es ir
sumando múltiplos de todo este vector
entonces si partimos de aquí y empezamos
a sumar todos los múltiplos vamos a
tener todos estos múltiplos todos estos
y luego también todos los múltiplos
negativos muy bien entonces lo que
obtuvimos es que cualquier punto sobre
esta línea al aplicarle la
transformación va a pegar justo en este
punto qué pasaría si por ejemplo nos
tomamos otro es digamos el menos 5 el
menos 55 que es justamente el inverso
aditivo de este entonces haciendo
exactamente el mismo razonamiento pues
vamos a pasar por el menos 50 que está
por aquí está por aquí y después vamos a
sumarle todos los múltiplos de 31
entonces
esencialmente
es una recta paralela a la que ya
teníamos pero que pasa por el menos 50
ok entonces todo esto es muy interesante
hemos hecho muchas cosas muy abstractas
digamos y creo que puede ser
completamente satisfactorio ahora que ya
hemos visto algo digamos más concreto en
este ejemplo pero pero realmente estoy
haciendo todo esto por una razón y
quiero entender cuál es el conjunto
solución a una ecuación no homogénea es
decir una ecuación de esta forma las
homogéneas es cuando aquí tenemos el
vector cero entonces quiero entender el
conjunto solución de una ecuación no
homogénea general como esta que acabo de
enmarcar ok entonces en principio vamos
a pensar qué pasa si nos tomamos el 0 es
decir qué pasa si nos tomamos la
ecuación homogénea la ecuación
x igual a cero bueno pues esto el
conjunto solución según esta expresión
que tenemos aquí es el conjunto 0 0 + x
2 por el vector 3 1 verdad entonces este
realmente no pinta no pinta pero si lo
dibujamos aquí pues me dice que pasa por
el 0 con la dirección del 31 entonces
esto se ve justamente así que también es
una línea paralela a las que ya había
obtenido pero recordemos muy bien quién
es esto esto la solución de esta
ecuación no es otra cosa más que el
núcleo o el espacio nulo de nuestra
transformación es el espacio nulo
entonces esta línea de aquí es el
espacio nulo de nuestra matriz entonces
esto esto realmente no pinta lo que me
está diciendo es que el espacio nulo
de la matriz o de la transformación es
justamente esta recta que si podemos ver
el conjunto solución en general de esta
ecuación homogénea aquí podemos ubicar
que tenemos también al espacio nulo al
espacio nulo entonces lo que estaríamos
pensando es que si tenemos una ecuación
muy general de este estilo
quizás sería conveniente pensar lo que
es el espacio nulo trasladado por un
vector entonces lo que estamos pensando
ya en general es suponiendo suponiendo
que esta ecuación a x igual a b tiene
solución tienes unas al menos solo al
menos una solución
ok entonces el conjunto solución
el conjunto solución si nos damos cuenta
para para ver cualquiera particular pues
es el el espacio nulo trasladado por un
vector entonces éste será un vector
particular que de hecho ya después
veremos quién es más si le sumamos el
espacio no lo es decir si lo trasladamos
al espacio nulo por un vector entonces
esto lo podemos ver geométricamente aquí
no lo he demostrado pero al menos
estamos buscando la intuición de esto y
nos va a servir muchísimo cuando
queramos entender bien las funciones o
las transformaciones que son uno a uno o
inyectaba es decir que son aquellas que
tienen a lo más
a una solución verdad una solución ya
hemos visto la definición de que sea
inyectaba o que sea uno a uno y en ese
sentido estaremos pensando que el
conjunto si queremos que esto se tenga a
lo más una solución entonces deberá
hacer este verdad el espacio nulo podría
tener varios entonces para que esto sea
sólo una solución el espacio nulo solo
puede tener sólo tiene al vector 0 ok
entonces esto lo haré de forma más
rigurosa en el próximo vídeo pero creo
que a veces cuando uno lo hace muy
riguroso no necesariamente catch a uno
bien la intuición pero esto va a ser muy
interesante
creo que si ya has entendido verás que
todo esto nos está llevando a
condiciones para que una transformación
sea invertible